[CHATTER]
ROBOT: You've made your point.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEVIN WANG: Hello, handsome.
ROBOT: [BARK]
KEVIN WANG: Up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW HOUCK: We've
had students make cars
that balance on
robots, cars that
play soccer, cars that can
balance on two wheels, cars
that pretend they're animals.
We've also had students get
rid of vehicles altogether.
Basically, anything that
students can think of
is fair game.
I'm Andrew Houck.
I am a professor in
electrical engineering
and one of the two
professors for our Car Lab.
In junior year, we
really want to give them
a project that sort of brings
all of the things they've
learned so far.
HALEY CHOW: It
all comes together
in a project where
we can build a robot.
And it is a pretty cool
way to acquire knowledge.
ANDREW HOUCK: At Princeton,
we want students to really
be creative thinkers.
Their final project,
they have six weeks
to order the parts they need,
get them here, build them
into a system, debug it,
work out all the kinks.
HALEY CHOW: So right now, we
have soccer-playing robot.
DANA FESJIAN: Tomorrow
during the demo,
the car will back up to
try to locate the ball.
And then it will go
towards it, and then circle
and score the goal.
JAMES ALMEIDA: I don't think
anyone has ever gotten anything
on the first try in Car Lab.
If they did, that
would be a miracle.
KATY HO: Our goal is to
make a robot dog car that
responds to different commands.
Originally the dog's name was
Duncan, which is my dog's name.
KEVIN WANG: But we also
found that it actually
doesn't respond very
well to the word Duncan.
So instead we've been using
the phrase, "Hello, handsome."
ZACH KENDRICK: Our
goal is to shoot
a ball that's flying through
the air with a Nerf bullet
like this.
CHLOE SONG: Hopefully
by tomorrow,
which is the final
demo day, we'll
be able to show the turret
actually shooting something.
JAMES ALMEIDA: We
designed a robot
that can balance on a ball.
Basically it has four
wheels and four motors.
TONY JIN: The ultimate
goal is to have it be
like the BB-8 from Star Wars.
ANDREW HOUCK: So this
is actually my car.
I was among the first
classes to actually take
Car Lab when I was an
undergraduate here in 1999.
Now students, they
can do so much more.
What used to be the
final is now really
just the sort of
stepping-off point.
The purpose of Car Lab is
really to get people to use
a whole array of sensors.
In the last 10 or
20 years, we've
really developed
ways that machines
can see the world around
them, digital cameras that
can do vision, sonar that can
sense the distance, temperature
sensors, magnetic field sensors.
This sort of marriage of the
physical world with data,
and information,
and computation is
really critical for
everything going forward.
TONY JIN: I would like
to do more with robotics
and hopefully get
to the point where
you see these robots in
movies that are intelligent,
that can help humans
with different things.
DANA FESJIAN: In the future, we
can theoretically do anything.
ANDREW HOUCK: This is why
people want to become engineers.
You take an idea, and
you turn it into reality.
[MUSIC PLAYING]